كما تزال المعارك على اشدها لحسم السيطره
على باخمد فقد اعلنت مجموعه تحقيق تقدم
جديد في المنطقه الصناعيه التي تشهد قتالا
عنيفا مع تحصن القوات الاوكرانيه داخلها
وقد ذكرت في بيان لها ان قواتها تمكنت من
السيطره على بلده زيانونسكي رغم نقص
امدادات الذخيره والسلاح
واشارت الى اقتراب تطويق مدينه بالكامل
حيث نشرت صوره تشير الى سيطرتها على خمس
مدن محيطه بالمدينه
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين اعلن ان
بلاده تعمل بنشاط على زياده قدرتها
الانتاجيه للاسلحه الجديده واكد بوتين على
اهميه زياده انتاج السلاح في الوقت الحالي
ومستقبل مشيرا الى ضروره اشراف المدعين
العامي على تحديث مؤسسات الصناعه الدفاعيه
بما في ذلك زياده القدرات لانتاج اسلحه
اضافيه
وفي تطورات الطائره الامريكيه المسيره
التي تحطمت بالامس اكد مدير الاستخبارات
الخارجيه الروسيه سيرجينا ريشيكي ان
الولايات المتحده تقوم بعمليات استطلاع
نشطه في منطقه البحر الاسود باستخدام
وسائل التكنولوجيه مختلفه وقال ناريشكين
ان الامريكيين يستخدمون بنشاط كبير جميع
الوسائل خصوصا الاستطلاع البصري
والاستطلاع اللاسلكي وقال سكرتيرو مجلس
الامن الروسي ان موسكو تحاول ايضا العثور
على حطام المسيره الامريكيه في مياه البحر
الاسود
في مقابل ذلك اكد الكرملين عدم وجود
اتصالات روسيه امريكيه رفيعه المستوى بعد
حادثه المسيره فوق البحر الاسود
واشار المتحدث باسم رئاسه الروسيه الى ان
روسيا مستعده للانخراط في اي حوار بناء
المسيرات الامريكيه كانت قد تحطمت بعد
صدامها بمقاتله روسيه فوق البحر الاسود
وبحسب الجيش الامريكي حاول الطائرتان
روسيتان اعتراض الطائره المسيره الامريكيه
مع ايقاف تشغيل اجهزه الارسال والاستقبال
الخاصه بها
الحادث وقع في حوالي الساعه السابعه
بتوقيت وسط اوروبا واستمر ما بين ثلاثين
الى اربعين دقيقه حسب الجيش الامريكي
وقد تحطمت الطائره المسيره بعد مناوره
حاده مع فقدانها تماما وقد نفت روسيا حدوث
اي تلامس مع طائره روسيه ما تسبب في سقوط
المسيره
ولعده مرات قبل الاصطدام القت مقاتلتان
روسيتان من طراز سخوي 27 الوقود نحو
الطائرات المسيره بطريقه متهوره وغير
سليمه بيئيا ومهنيا وفق الجيش الامريكي
ومن ثم صدمت احدى المقاتلتين الروسيتين
مروحه هذه المسيره وهو مضطر القوات
الامريكيه الى اسقاطها في المياه الدوليه
من احدث المسيرات الامريكيه تمتلك مواصفات
تكنولوجيه عاليه
يعتمد عليها الجيش الامريكي في العمليات
العسكريه
سرعتها تصل الى 300
كيلومترا في الساعه
قادره على التحليق لمده تصل الى اكثر من
30 ساعه تصنف بالطائره متعدده المهام
القدره على الرصد والمراقبه ومهاجمه اهداف
على الارض يمكن تسليحها بصواريخ هيل فاير
وكذلك بقنابل موجهه بالليزر نفذت ام كيو 9
مهمه في العراق وافغانستان وسوريا ودول
اخرى وفق تقارير استخدمت في اغتيال قاسم
سليماني وفي اغتيال زعيم تنظيم القاعده
ايمن الظواهري صحيفه واشنطن بوست تشغيل
الدرون ام كيو 9 يتم عن بعد بواسطه فريقين
في نحو 20 قاعده منتشره في 17 ولايه
امريكيه